you showed such a beautiful human side
to all the members in the band and I
know one part are different parts where
our nel would say I want to go home like
you've just felt it here's this these
people lining up waiting to see the show
it's scary
yes it's a dream come true but you could
feel why that would happen and then you
mentioned in a Q&A that there was a
circle of trust and at first you were
way out in no man's land anywhere inst
your way in I think persistence because
we were there every day like you know
when they agreed to have to have us come
on board and film them film this Oh a
tour I think they understood it
cerebrally but they didn't really
understand it in their hearts like what
that meant um for our veteran band they
were not used to cameras and you know
cameras following them around which
surprised me I thought you know there's
such veterans they're used to media or
just attention or just camera the
presence of the camera but someone
explained to me recently well they're
also and because they're veterans
because they came of age like at the
cusp of like MTV when it all happened
right when suddenly in the back store
the back door the backstage was
something to be filmed you know what I
advent of MTV they came at that cus so
they're not really used to having
cameras so it makes sense they're not
used to having cameras around backstage
and stuff I thought they were so it
surprised me man they were like you're
still here well you know what's
happening why are you still wanting to
shoot them you filmed this every day but
you know it's like a take another
regular film rights hopefully one thing
works I'm not shouting out action but
basically in my head I'm like okay
action and then you do it again the next
day and one take hits that's basic in
documentary filmmaking but I think it
was when they realized we weren't going
away they realized okay they're here
we've promised some access we'll give
them access one thing about the band is
and they told me this is very beginning
their a handshake band I'm like really
you don't have any contracts because
truthfully we didn't have the rights
for the music when we were filming but
they said you know we're a handshake man
we said we're gonna work it you know
we'll make it work for you we've agreed
to do this we're gonna be there for you
though you know we have your back and
they did at the end of the day they did
I mean we've watched it we show them the
film and we were done in last year right
before premiering for Tribeca they saw
it they loved it and everything you know
of course then the lawyers started
talking back and forth but at the end of
the day they did still grant us rights
yeah I think it was just persistence
when they realized you know there's this
great story of um and I always tell this
story you know we were filming Neil and
he always has his guitar even in the
film right she's always playing this
guitar I think we're filming him it's
really quiet in the dressing room he's
playing playing playing and we were
there for a good 10 minutes it was me
Julia my cinematographer and Jim I was
doing sound then we just sitting and I
love doing that just being there and
just filming and just being quiet and
Zen and in the moment and he is into it
ok for a good ten minutes and then he
looks up and he goes you're still here
I'm like yeah meow we're still here
until you go home when you go home we go
home yes okay man I knew then I know
okay
we've got you've reached the kind of
access that you know I dreamt up because
he forgot we were there you know
you